Reagan was the voice of Wall Street he
was the embodiment of free enterprise
and money and success and that's what
that's what the people at the top of
Hollywood always want it hi I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer for reason TV and today
we're talking with William stadium
author of the new book money would
Hollywood in its last age of excess bill
thanks for talking to us nice to be here
your book speculates on how Hollywood
left it's golden age 30 40 years ago
could you just talk about this
transformation and some of the changes
you've written about well it's it's a
good story because the last if you call
it a golden age was the seventies the
directors sort of resurrected a dying
Hollywood in in the late 50s and 60s
Hollywood was terrible is in bad shape
and people are watching television they
didn't want to go out America was
becoming more suburban eyes and people
loved watching leave it to beaver at
home and why should they go out to a
movie theater and it was plenty of
movies on TV it wasn't very good but it
was easier than going out and there was
a lot of urban unrest and you know civil
violence and things that people didn't
like going to the movie theaters and in
the 70s the sort of new wave of De Palma
and Scorsese and and Coppola they came
in made some interesting movies and also
the baby boomers were starting to come
evasion they could buy tickets and these
people were probably the baby boomers
were a fairly intellectual group of
people despite sort of hippie movement
they were kind of brainy and they were
mass college educated at that time and
they responded to these movies like mean
streets and The Godfather and all these
a lot of terrific movies were starting
to come out what happened in the 80s is
basically these people knew how to make
blockbuster movies and Wall Street took
notice of this and I said we want to get
in on this action so Hollywood got
became a target of Wall Street and they
started buying in but what they were
buying was not the art they were buying
the money and that's why the book is
called money would and what really money
would is about is about this kind of an
easy or uneasy relationship between the
Wall Street money people and the people
here in Hollywood who were the mogul you
mentioned that the 50s were that people
were more focused on TV than the movies
and in Atlantic article just came out
saying we're entering the golden age of
television would you agree with that TV
it's gotten very very sophisticated
because you can tell a long-form story
you have many episodes to get into the
nuance of things and used to be in the
80s when TV I mean 80 so it's about
Dallas a dynasty and these kind of big
blockbuster shows it sort of reflected
Reagan and his kitchen cabinet they were
a dynasty and the people he was friends
with were very dynastic and what that
was more soap opera stuff now with the
HBO and then the sopranos and all these
shows they've gotten very very
sophisticated and if you want to tell
that kind of nuanced story that's the
place to do it going to the theater for
a two-hour Batman movie is not the place
to do it there's these online only
platforms now like you mentioned HBO or
HBO go and there's original content for
netflix and hulu what else can we expect
from the digital age i think technology
is changing every day who would have
guessed that the VCR would become
obsolete and there the DVD is passed in
five years who knows what delivery
systems we have but in any case they can
make better and better quality that's
more and more targeted to individual
taste and that's where TV can deliver so
now you in the comfort of home you can
see a TV show that looks better than the
old cinema scope and Technicolor of the
50s there's Reagan and there's a lot of
overlaps between Hollywood and politics
could you talk a little bit about some
of these examples well it was really you
know the 80s or the age of Reagan now
what one thinks of Hollywood is a
left-wing democratic liberal liberal
community well most of the actors and
writers and the you know sort of
artistic people in Hollywood truly are
kind of Liberal Democrat types the
studio heads the Warner's the mayor's
Selznick there were always Republicans
they always they want it to be accepted
they wanted to be they
wanted to be on Wall Street that was
fine with them they thought it was great
and Reagan was the voice of Wall Street
he was the embodiment of free enterprise
and money and success and that's what
that's what the people at the top of
Hollywood always want it and that's what
even the more liberal people at the
bottom of Hollywood once they got to the
top they decided they wanted it to the
Republicans were basically had a message
of self-reliance so once these people
had made it and we're successful they
said Republican ideology appeal to them
more they said yeah we've made it we're
successful everybody can make if we can
make it you can make it and so they have
this kind of mentality so the people who
are running the studio's all were
Republicans and in in the 80s Reagan was
you know his kitchen cabinet were all
Hollywood kind of people none of them
had succeeded in Hollywood but all of
them had wanted to 68 or many of them
specifically in California you know the
high cost of production here has really
forced a lot of companies to move
elsewhere so do you think that old
Hollywood nostalgia is forever gone with
them yes I think we'll never see
Hollywood as a place where movies are
mating where I think now hollowing what
is a place where deals are done more
than anything else but I think they'll
still be a lot of Technology going on
here in Los Angeles so I don't think
that Hollywood will ever become a ghost
town but it's really a town of high-tech
special effects can be all done here at
the studio that the studios will become
sort of campuses of Technology well
thanks again for talking to us I enjoyed
it friesen TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
you